aéroport de nikolaïev ces soldats
ukrainien embusqués tirent sur une
colonne russe
c'est un coup direct aucun blindage ne
résiste aux missiles antichars et les
forces russes en sont régulièrement
victimes comme ici dans la banlieue de
kiev pour utiliser ces missiles de type
jaglin il suffit de deux soldats avec
une portée de 2 km et demi
dix sept mille unités ont été fournies
par l'otan à l'ukraine des missiles très
facile à juminer sur la ligne de front
dans le nord-est c'est dans le coffre
des voitures de civils que ces missiles
sont livrés par dizaines
et pour montrer qu'ils sont vraiment
très facile à utiliser les forces
spéciales ukrainienne publie un mode
d'emploi complet sur les réseaux sociaux
les ukrainiens peuvent aussi compter sur
les missiles antiaériens de type stinger
qui leur sont livrés en masse tirées
depuis le sol ils atteignent toujours
leurs cibles et pour les équipages
russes c'est devenu une hantise rouge
quand
l'armée russe n'a pas la possibilité
aujourd'hui de voler en haute altitude
parce que certains de ces jeunes sont
cinq ans pas capable de le faire pour
larguer des arbres et contre volant très
basse altitude du coup on se retrouve à
portée de tir des missiles tirés depuis
l'épaule on a livré un millier
d'exemplaires a le crâne le dernier
atout des ukrainiens c'est le drone
bayrac tard de fabrication turc plus
difficiles à repérer par les russes ils
sont capables d'emporter des missiles à
150 km pour frapper des cibles au sol au
total entre les états unis et l'union
européenne l'ukraine doit recevoir pour
770 millions d'euros d'armes et de
matériel la france pourrait livrer des
missiles antichars milan utilisé par nos
forces au sahel